die csu gibt sich gerne als law and
order partei aber ausgerechnet ihr
vorsitzender ignoriert seit jahren die
rechtssprechung und weigert sich diese
verbote in betracht zu ziehen
ich hätte mich todesmutig an die fersen
von markus s
ich stehe hier mit dem rechtsanwalt herr
petzold form stadelheim dem knast in
münchen denn es könnte sein dass söder
dabei drin sitzt die würden die ersten
tage in erzwingungshaft für söder
aussehen er würde eingecheckt werden die
werden ärztlich untersucht und müssen
sich komplett entkleiden und dürfen auch
nichts mitnehmen die kriegen dann die
anstaltskleidung das dauert manchmal
auch schon relativ langen da hängt man
dann rum und weiß nicht wie es geht also
immer wieder berichtet dass man auch
fragt wie lange sitze ich hier noch und
dann wird man angeblafft man habe sich
unterzuordnen und nicht so blöde fragen
zu stellen
man kann alle drei tage duschen glauben
sie markus söder könnte sich im knast
gänge anschließen
also man sagt dass manche gefängnisse
tatsächlich so eine hand von weißrussen
oder irgendwie sind spricht von mafiösen
situationen ich glaube aber dass ich
einen langsamen der hoch arbeiten
müssten und aber das schafft das weiß
ich nicht
meine nachforschungen haben ergeben
markus es taucht gerne auf volksfesten
abend wir sind gegen
sind ja sehr bürgernaher typ der sich
auch normale berufe vorstellen können in
einer wäscherei zu arbeiten zum beispiel
ich habe vorher normalen beruf gehabt
ich war mal journalist also ich habe
auch mal beim fernsehen gearbeitet aber
das war mir dann zu wenig arbeit und ich
wollte dann doch ausgeschaltet und
wäscherei wäre jetzt zum beispiel weil
das können sie ja vielleicht bald machen
droht ja beugehaft weil sie sich weigert
diese verbote umzusetzen ja ich würde
eher sagen journalisten cdf der kamera
schmutzige wäsche waschen das passt auch
noch schmutziger als einfach gesetze
nicht umzusetzen
aber da macht man ja so viel unsinn und
man musste nie folgen befürchten das ist
ja der große vorteil so einen job aber
kann er den ganzen tag was erzählen wie
sie und keiner ist bekommt sogar noch
gebühren dafür das gefühl sie tor flogen
sind machen und müssen folgende fürchten
welcher ministerpräsident stellt sich
über das gesetz
keiner außer die fans auch wirklich cool
also ein gericht entscheidet ist diese
fahrverbote anordnen und sie ignorieren
sie einfach einen stimmt überhaupt nicht
wir haben das ja alles geübt haben sie
an strafzahlungen gemacht wenn der start
strafe zahlt wo geht das an den start
sie waren ja nicht abgewählt ich kann er
abgewählt wenn ich muss mir jeden tag
der verantwortung stellen sie können den
ganzen tag einfach einen schönen tag
machen sie haben gar keine angst nein
überhaupt nicht
kraft nein von handschellen aber ja das
können sie für persönliche andere dinge
für welpen mache ich auch tatsächlich
ein see her so da würde sich im knast
einer gänge anschließen einer gang was
wir anerkennen so was wie die csu oder
hat im knast
sie holen hier raus ich hole ihn wieder
raus weil diese nur punktes attac ist
und nichts mit bayern zu tun aber wenn
ein gericht entscheidet hier müssen
diese fahrverbote eingeführt werden kann
man das dann einfach ignorieren
gerichtsurteile kann man ja meine
kreativen er so da kann's wo der
ignoriert es seit 2014 bei welchem eine
stadt in münchen in münchen
ich hatte das geld was würden sie ihm im
knast besuchen ja selbstverständlich
wird zugang casey kuchen kriegen und
käse eingebaut der feind nicht würde
ihnen auch retten sie würden ihn auch ja
klar zum gleis fahren einbrechen so da
rausholen werden alles er kann machen
was er will wir sind da eben lieber
markus da dieser trupp würdig aus dem
knast befreien ich sag mal auch das team
ist in die jahre gekommen und damit
zurück ins studio
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag menschen überall
lassen die ihre dreggsagg michl liegen
und ihr lasst jetzt slx ein beschissenes
abo da
[Musik]